un jour cette ville sera peut être
détruite en quelques heures c'est
presque deux millions d'habitants
pourrait disparaître s'ils n'ont pas fui
à temps
yoga carta capitale culturelle premier
centre universitaire de l'indonésie ne
serait plus qu'un souvenir
vous n'y croyez pas c'est déjà arrivé il
y à milan un incroyable si elle de
cendres englouti d'un coup la ville la
civilisation hindous mataram septembre
ces trésors disparu
le responsable il sommeille pour
l'instant à 25 kilomètres à vol d'oiseau
d'ici bas il est le plus actif de toute
la chaîne des volcans qui traverse l'île
de java
on l'appelle merapi la montagne de feu
en javanais
[Musique]
si bien que pour prévenir les colères du
merapi
on l'a ceinturé d'une guirlande de cette
station d'observation
pacnews dirige celle de call you wrong
un village du flanc sud à seulement deux
kilomètres et demi du cratère de manière
très détaillée tous les aspects visuels
du volcan est aussi la météo si laquelle
elle soulève les brûle on écoute le
bruit des chutes de rochers et quand il
fait beau on s'intéresse à la couleur
des fumoirs blanc ou gris
c'est ce qui nous renseigne on analyse
les données du sismographe d'autres
instruments installés sur le sommet du
merapi qui nous a dit que la température
du sol
la pluviométrie la force du vent c'est
ça nous permet d'imaginer l'état du
créateur
près de cinquante fonctionnaires à
l'écouté du moindre hoquet volcaniques
d'une certaine manière le merapi
multirécidiviste est devenue l'alliée de
la fonction publique
[Musique]
trizno glaneuse de bois respecte le
contrat sur les flancs du merapi seuls
les arbres morts asphyxiés par les gaz
du cratère peuvent être prélevées aux
forêts protégées rempart naturel aux
éruptions du bois de chauffage à l'envi
mais faut supporter les colères de celui
que trizno nomme familièrement combat le
vieux ou qui avait troqué sa majesté au
long pif histoire de conjurer les
mauvais souvenirs
c'était vraiment un moment de panique il
faisait tout noir plus une seule lumière
pour les enfants c'était épouvantable
nous avons dû nous enfuir courir il y
avait une voisine qui s'est trompé au
lieu de prendre son fils elle avait pris
l'oreiller dans ses bras
c'était très difficile
[Musique]
pas commode ce merapi en période
d'activité sur dôme qui grossit et
s'alourdit des matériaux expulsé du
cratère par dizaines de milliers de
mètres cubes tous les jours
puis soudain ce dôme qui s'effondre sur
lui même en une formidable avalanche
sèche de blocs de lave incandescente et
de cendres en suspension et le to qui
dévale la pente à plus de 250 km à
l'heure une nuée ardente qu'en général
on n'a pas trop le temps de voir venir
un coup lendemain
ce jour là j'ai couru de toutes mes
forces
j'ai abandonné toutes mes affaires où la
loupe on m'avait laissé derrière eux y a
et puis on a été évacué en camion les
enfants pleurer et crier partout
non vraiment c'est pas un souvenir
agréable ça reste gravé dans la tête
[Musique]
sans bois de chauffe pour cuire saurait
ici on n'est rien sans lherm tellement
grâce des pentes du merapi
pas de vache finalement prise non et les
siens s'accommode des colères du vieux
pourvu qu'ils les gardent de quelques
privilèges
[Musique]
d'ailleurs c'est à se demander si au
lieu de le fuir les javanais tous
ensemble au désespoir des vulcanologues
de s'accrocher aux pentes du merapi
[Musique]
chacun avec ses raisons déjà au piémont
du volcan pas une friche pas un lopin
qu'ils ne soient cultivés
rien que ce chant il donne au moins deux
quintes only je crois oui deux quintaux
facile on fait trois récoltes de riz par
an sur cette terre quoi récolte les
poussières du merapi en un terreau
fertile
nous appelons la terre ici est bonne
c'est comme les sable et les rochers
dans nos rivières c'est bon pour
l'agriculture plus au bout de la route
c'est le hameau de keyyo m 1500 m
d'altitude est sacré point de vue sur la
gueule fumantes du merapi idéal pour
prendre le frais et emmené un petit
flirt
car comme d'autres patinent sur les lacs
le javanais lui aime depuis toujours
venir frissonner sous le merapi
madame en bio et quelques autres
bistrotiers ont longtemps fait commerce
de cette fascination et puis un jour
c'est le volcan lui-même qui s'est
invitée à la buvette de madame angot et
des marchands de souvenirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toujours à l'époque
ici il y avait mon petit kiosque et ma
maison mais maintenant il ne reste plus
rien tout a été balayé par des sables et
des rochers et toya je suis très triste
c'est après l'époque c'était un site
touristique qu'il y avait beaucoup plus
de monde avec mon petit kiosque que je
vivais bien aujourd'hui ça n'a plus rien
à voir
[Musique]
il ya un cocktail au bar
bien sûr que j'ai peur des nuées
ardentes c'était de revenir à tout
moment via les à force qu'on s'habitue à
tap fini par oublier la peur et puis les
catastrophes ça n'arrive pas seulement
dans les montagnes cdu a décidé que ma
maison était ici il n'est rien à dire on
va continuer difficile
[Musique]
chacun semble donc ici faire son miel à
vivre près du merapi mais ce n'est rien
en comparaison de christian ah oui
désigné par le sultan de yogyakarta
homme de l'année 2001 s'il prête de
temps en temps ses yeux la station de
surveillance de qu'elle lui rende
christian chef de la sécurité du flanc
sud le plus dangereux du volcan a
toujours su conduire les opérations de
secours a tant mieux avec un temps
d'avancé
depuis quarante ans qu'il arpente sous
le cratère forêts rivières coulées de
cendres il sait prendre le pouls du
vieux merapi comme personne et en
bretagne en avant toutes ces recherches
ces techniques de surveillance des
volcans les habitants disent y avaient
leur façon à eux de pressentir l'état du
merapi le premier signe ce sont les
oiseaux
ils se regroupent et pousse des cris
s'agite et s'éloignent à grande vitesse
on sait que merapi prépare quelque chose
ensuite ce sont les chiens du village il
se met à aboyer en regardant dans la
direction du cratère intenable ça c'est
le deuxième signal
enfin on voit d'un coup tous les
serpents qui sortent de terre
il s'ensuit parce que la terre se
réchauffe ils le sont avant tout le
monde
il traverse même les rues du village
quand on additionne ces trois cimes
c'est qu'il est temps de prendre ses
affaires et de fiche le camp
si ailleurs la lave par sa viscosité
épouse la topographie des pentes et
dévalé les nuées ardentes du merapi
ravage tout sur leur passage en taille
profondément le flanc du volcan qui les
crashs malheur à qui se trouvent sur
leur chemin
mais ici le malheur des uns fait le
labeur des autres
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à peine refroidi la coulée de cendres
est devenu mine à ciel ouvert
propriété de personne donc de tout le
monde en priorité des villageois
alentours qui ont perdu pâture jardins
vergers ou maison en bon seigneur
le merapi repar'stores pense-t-on ici
oui dix habitent un village à deux
heures de marche de la mine elle vient
quand elle veut creuse où elle veut
autant qu'elle veut suffit de s'entendre
avec une voisine un parent et venir
creuser le volume d'une benne la seule
unité de mesure qui va ici une benne de
sable ses cinquante mille roupies 4
euros ces légendes et camions qui payent
pour venir dans cette carrière faut
payer 5000 roupies à l'entrée ici ils ne
prennent que le sable sans lesquels on
passe qui me paye directement sur place
ces pratiques comme ça j'ai l'argent
tout de suite faut dire que les
chantiers pullulent dans la vallée car
prévoyant le merapi a parachevé sa
dernière éruption là tremblement de
terre qui a détruit 30 % des
constructions de yoga carte à une
aubaine pour les marchands de berne
[Musique]
si le merapi va exposer de nouveaux sans
aucun doute quand dans cinq à six ans
tout le monde le pense ou sur ses flancs
sud et ouest en conviennent les
spécialistes avec quelle force d'une
telle ampleur probablement en attendant
en attendant on voit passer dans les
villages des processions charger une
offrande à l'attention du vieux
cracheurs de feu une garantie qu'ils ne
mangent qu'un peu de fronde trizno la
glaneuse pas claude d'amours guillot
christian widi des autres ont appris à
faire ami ami avec celui qui leur donne
tout reprend ce qu'il a donné puis
redonne ce qu'il a pris n'est pas votre
ennemi celui qui vous prévient de ses
colères juste un ami difficile à vivre
[Musique]